ليله صوت الارض ليله فنيه هي الاضخم تكرم
علما من اعلام الفن العربي وعمودا من
اعمده الاغنيه السعوديه وعلى الرغم من
مرور 22 عاما على رحيله الا ان صوت طلال
مداح ما زال عالقا في الذاكره بالفعل نجوم
العرب اجتمعوا في تظاهر فنيه سعوديه
خليجيه عربيه كبرى تكريما لصوت مؤرخ
الاغنيه السعوديه طلال مداح كان محور ليلى
ليست ككل الليالي على مسرح محمد عبده
وايضا بمبادره من هيئه الترفيه في
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بالامس كانت ليله تاريخيه كانت ليله
فريده من نوعها
عاشها الطلاليين بكل تفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
بوتقى من اجمل الاصوات العربيه
كانت متواجده معانا في الحفل
[موسيقى]
واعتقد انها حتكون ليله تخلد
تخلي التاريخيه
استاذ عبد الله
يعني فعلا كانت ليله ساحره وفوق الخيال
بكل المقاييس استاذ عبد الله في العاده
لكل فنان جمهوره لكن بالنسبه للراحل طلال
مداح لا يختلف عليه اثنان اما من
السعوديين او حتى من الفنانين العرب ومن
الجمهور العرب بالتالي عفويه وبساطه طلال
كانسان كيف انعكست على فنه وعلى جوده
حفلاته
خلينا نقول انه تميز
الوالد رحمه الله عليه كان في بساطته وكان
في
عفويته في تواضعه
فكان قريب
لجمهوره قريب
للشخص العادي
المستمع
فهذه اثرت تاثير كثير على
خلينا نقول جمهور في العالم سواء في
العالم العربي او في
عندنا خصوصا يعني
ما اعتقد انه
حنلقى شخص مثلا
ما يحب او يكره
طلال رحمه الله عليه
اما انه يحبوا لشخصه او يحبوا لفنه او
يحبوا لجزئيه ما في في شخصيته
وهذا
خلينا نقول انها هي نعمه من نعم الله عليه
انه يكون عنده هذا هذا القبول عند
المجتمع وعند الجمهور يعني
طيب السيد عبد الله يعني على رغم روتين
وعشرين عاما على رحيل الفنان الكبير طلال
مداح يعني لا تزال اغاني مخلده عربيا
والسعوديا ما هي المعايير التي جعلته
فنانا يخلد للاغنيه السعوديه خصوصا نقدر
نقول انه
العوامل المحيطه به سواء ببداياته او حتى
في ظهور الفن
تعامله مع زي ما قلنا مع الجمهور ومع
المنحوله ساهم كثير في في هذا الشيء يعني
بساطته في حد ذاته
[موسيقى]
بتساهم انه
تكون انت اقرب للمستمعه
اللي هو خلينا نقول العادي المستمر
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
طلال في حد ذاته يعني كوالدي من الصعب اني
انا اتكلم عنه
على قولهم
بالمديح لانه مهما كان فهو والدي يعني
فاكيد حمده لكن تميزه
في نظر جمهوره
هو اكبر تميز
[موسيقى]